vraiment un cauchemar salle était
incroyable elle n'y croyait presque plus
après 40 heures d'attentes cindy charles
entier enfin les passeports de ces
enfants entre ses mains le départ est
prévu demain à 7 heures c'était pas
facile du tout parce que dans le fond on
attend ici de jour de soir et de nuit je
peux vous dire que maintenant c'est la
joie ils peuvent quitter c'est en
quelque sorte la files d'attentes de la
dernière chance ces gens espèrent tous
réussir à monter à bord de leur avion
dans les prochaines heures c'est très
frustrant comme situation on a fait
notre demande début avril avec ça fait
deux mois et demi bonne nouvelle notre
voyage et demain dire que cette personne
au delà de 48 heures la semaine dernière
je suis venu et genre et expliquer la
situation pour cette semaine puis mon
exprimant ils mangeraient demandé de
rebrousser chemin c'est une chance à
tout le monde
à l'intérieur du complexe guy-favreau
les patients se fait de plus en plus
sentir les policiers ont été appelés en
renfort pour assurer lors
la situation est loin d'être unique déjà
entendent aussi au bureau de toronto de
vancouver et de laval notamment le jour
mais aussi la nuit la pression monte sur
le gouvernement trudeau la moitié de nos
impôts au gouvernement fédéral donc
c'est pas normal que les services soient
aussi dysfonctionnelle je comprends qu
ait de la pression je comprends que ça
peu difficile des x games la rareté mais
deux on comprend que les gens font face
à des délais inacceptables une situation
extrêmement difficile mais nous
continuons le travail à tous les jours
les gens sont en train de travailler 12
14 16
chaque jours déjà et ils ont besoin de
sept ans pour justement procès c'est un
fait mais les passeports mais pour les
députés de l'opposition ce n'est pas
suffisant on ne ment pas d'aller danser
salue le moment de délivrer des
passeports avec le minimum de temps le
gouvernement fédéral veut embaucher 600
personnes pour accélérer le traitement
des demandes des ressources pourraient
être réaffectés des discussions sont en
cours avec d'autres ministères ici qui
me permettrait au canada montréal